NARRATOR: At the start of the
1900s,
Americans couldn't even envision
a future that included trucks.
If you think about the
early part of the 1900s,
we were still in the
horse and buggy era.
NARRATOR: Between actual
horses and iron horses,
our hauling needs were met.
Adding an automotive option
seemed an absurd indulgence.
Keep in mind, at that
point, the automobile
was a very sophisticated thing,
and rich people had them.
NARRATOR: But the auto
world would soon give rise
to two familiar names
who would become
the first titans of trucks.
And their battles of innovation
began early, when one of them
first made vehicles affordable.
His name was Ransom E. Olds.
ROBERT GABRICK: Ransom E. Olds
is one of these self made men,
who starts out working
in the machine shop
and becomes very successful
in the development of engines
and, of course, the motor car.
JEFF GLUCKER: He was a very
smart guy, ahead of his time.
I think at one point, he had
11 prototype vehicles made over
the course of like a few years.
There was a gas one, a steam
one, and even an electric one.
NARRATOR: But in 1904, Ransom's
relations with his investors
soured, forcing him to walk away
from the company he founded.
So he left Oldsmobile behind,
and formed a new company,
using his initials
as the name, REO.
He was the only Detroit
manufacturer to have two
car companies named after him.
NARRATOR: Ransom Olds
was now in position
to become a godfather
of the truck industry,
but he wasn't yet
ready to strike.
It was the other soon to be
titan who fired the first shot
in the truck wars, Henry Fold.
Ford first began
making cars in 1901,
joining a booming
industry that saw
the number of autos on
the road go from 8,000
in 1900 to 78,000 in 1905.
Ford, sensing an
opportunity, tried
to get a jump on the
market for a light duty
truck with the Model E.
The Model E delivery car
was Ford's first real attempt
at like a commercial vehicle.
It was about $950 in 1905,
which was a lot of money.
And they really only
sold 10 of them.
So it wasn't exactly a triumph.
NARRATOR: Ford would
lick his wounds,
learn from his mistakes, and go
on to perfect his passenger car
design with the iconic Model T.
REPORTER: In 1909 came
the revolutionary Model T.
1,700 were produced in that
first year, a miracle of
mass production for the time.
NARRATOR: Ford stormed to
the top of the car world.
But his earlier Model E flop
made him gun shy of entering
the truck market again.
So his customers started
doing it themselves,
kickstarting a truck
modding scene that's
still going strong today.
Ford was convinced that
all America needed to get by
was the Model T. He was wrong.
ERIC NOBLE: It was
farmers saying,
old Bessie can only
go 12 miles today.
I need to go 15 or 20.
What I want to do is take the
bed off the back of my farm
wagon, and I'm going to
just figure out how to put
that on the back of my Model T.
MATT ANDERSON: Americans
are an inventive bunch.
And if we want something,
we'll find a way to get it,
whether we have to go to
someone to build it for us,
or whether we just have
to build it ourselves.
NARRATOR: Yet, despite the
obvious demand for trucks,
Henry Ford still wasn't
ready to jump in.
Instead, he would be
beaten to the punch
once again by a familiar
competitor, Ransom Olds, whose
breakthrough design was
arguably the most influential
civilian truck of all time.
In 1915, the REO Motor Company
released the iconic REO
Speedwagon, scoring the first
major victory in the battle
for truck supremacy.
And while most autos were
stuck at the piddling industry
standard of 15 miles per
hour, the Speedwagon was
20% faster, earning its name.
It was also one of
the first trucks
to sport an electric
starter and pneumatic tires.
Combine those game changing
upgrades with its quickness,
and the Speedwagon blew
the doors open on what
a civilian truck could be.
STACEY DAVID: Crank
starting a car,
you know how you get on a car
now, and you hit the starter
and you let it wind, think
of that with your arm.
If it kicks back and
you're not ready for it,
it can break your arm.
It is not something that
you just do on a whim.
JASON TORCHINSKY:
Utility vehicles
and hauling vehicles before
then had hard rubber tires.
So pneumatic tires made
the ride softer and better.
And if you had cargo
that was fragile,
it was that much less shock
that you'd have on it.
NARRATOR: The Speedwagon
came out of the gate
with approximately 13,000
units in annual sales,
an impressive mark
considering its hefty price
of around $1,000.
It would also evolve
into numerous models,
from fire duty to farm duty,
over an impressive 38 year
run proving that trucks
were here to stay.
[music playing]